hello there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch The Last of
Us episode 8 today I'm assuming the
David chapter we are here joined with
Andrew Gordon Igor 7-Eleven
how are you I'm good almost as good as
your biceps but yes I'm excited to see
the David episode uh because I thought
he was one of the best written
characters in the game so I'm looking
forward to seeing what we're gonna get
that's great my biceps let's talk about
that you know why they look good today
because of this shirt
shop zero edition.com this is a real
rejects exclusive Last of Us inspired
shirt and don't worry if you haven't
played the game there is not a single
part of the game where Joel and Ellie
are doing the Shawn of the Dead ending
guys with that in mind go ahead and
leave a like that would mean a lot
wouldn't Andrew I think they should also
subscribe and click that notification
Bell get notified when our reaction for
the finales Rob is that right Andrew I
think you should also by the way full
interaction watch alongs where you sync
it with your own copy available for
super sexy rejects over our patreon page
we cover stuff exclusively over there
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included Andrew shut up let's get to it
revelation 21.
sure
and I heard a great voice out of Heaven
saying behold
and God shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes
wipe her tears away
do you remember what
Jesus killed the clickers and God will
wipe away all tears from their eyes do
you know what that means
he's so creepy his Cadence does sound a
lot like the original voice actor Noah
North yeah the ground is too cold to dig
we'll bury your father in the spring
bless you
we'll get through this oh we're gonna
get to know his people they're human too
they're not just horrible individuals
humanizing everyone even
Josiah and Martin think they spotted
some deer the other night
it was dark
see what you want to see sometimes
James
yeah it's Joe
I sensed out in there
like Thomas I still believe it's been uh
the last six months have been hard
here is Joe voice peeking through
now go get our guns we're going hunting
he said making part of David's team
that's interesting he's thirsty
why this does feel biblical
oh
[Music]
yeah look at her eye on the gun gotta
get some food it's cool seeing the
precursor yeah I like this
oh no bow narrow
stop comparing it to the game I'm sorry
I didn't mean to compare it
wow I love that they shot this on
location yes
I'm gonna miss the show all right
oh
that is
freezing
sounds like a clicker but I would assume
it's a deer
which you'll touch you that deer is an
[__]
oh
the blood trail yeah
[Music]
what do you think
I don't see anybody
you think we can just take it
don't drop your rifles
turn and face me slow
any sudden moves I put one right between
your eyes you know for Buddy boys
I won't say it twice please just 10
seconds we're not asking for charity we
we can trade you
for some of the deer we have what do you
need we have medicine
like for infections
not not for a bite follow us I'm not
following you anywhere
where buddy boy can go get it
right between my eyes
bring back two bottles and a syringe
it's not code James do as I said
wink
you look badass a while before James
gets back I have some oil and matches in
my package
take shelter
him with us
starting this off with leaning in on him
being a pastor makes this a very
different kind of dynamic the Optics
around it just yeah they hit you
differently they did hint at it in the
game but yes I agree you know you really
shouldn't be out here all on your own
from where I'm sitting you shouldn't be
at her on your own
for what it's worth there's room for you
in our group if you want
any inviting me to your hunger Club
thanks
I'm a decent man
trying to take care of the people who
rely on me
they chose to follow you
weird cult thing good question I am a
preacher
what the whole world ended and you still
believe that [__] I actually started
believing after the world ended
kids about your age
so he went from teacher to preacher
because what it [__] rhymes
well I found God after the apocalypse
which is either the best time or the
worst time to find him hard to say
yeah and as we wanted we picked up new
people along the way until we ended up
here we look at you right now sooner or
later luck
no such thing as luck
no I I believe everything happens for a
reason
sure we didn't expect this winner to be
so cruel
game's been hard to find so I sent four
of our people to a nearby Town ah
they're skipping it only three of them
came back and the one that didn't was a
father he had a daughter just like you
and her dad was taken from her ice he
was murdered by this crazy man that
crazy man
was traveling with a little girl
everything happens for a reason
James lower the gun
man did you bring the medicine
yeah throw it to her
David
it's Joel why are you telling to back
away and protect you
I'm so sad they skipped it
don't compare right now you'll have to
adjust Andrew
Joe where the [__] do I put this
Gamble
[Music]
oh
so sweet
yeah that's what I'm thinking too huh
what is it
do they not know whether
I don't know
seems like they keep it hidden from the
people
oh they just brought the deer in big one
oh did you tell them yes we found a girl
who was with the man who took Alec from
us
Rises I'll lead a group out to pick up
her Trail interesting we'll bring that
man to Justice
you kill him
you should kill both of them this is
really interesting yeah yeah wow I got
so many thoughts about this because
that's definitely setting up quite
something that I can't spoil
ah dude
[Music]
the truth is Hannah you will always have
a father
who will show him respect when he's
speaking
here
creep yeah
thank you
I know this is Icky oh
this is disturbing itself
are they eating hat
I think so yeah that's
despicably gross
I really like the Sinister additions
though not gonna lie it's awesome and
they are springboarding a lot of
thoughts
[Music]
callus
do you have a weapon Ally
can we bring that girl back with us
she's just another mouth to feed leave
her out here she'll die
yeah maybe that's God's will
oh no he's not a Believer smack him
question
[Music]
me that's a gunshot there are men coming
okay I'm gonna leave them away from you
but if anybody makes it down here she
can kill them you got it this is dead
do not fall asleep
oh
[Music]
Alice
oh nice shot done
[Music]
oh
callous
I got her
die
do it
oh no
I want Justice for Alec two of you with
me the rest of you stay here go door to
door you so hungry for vengeance
deliver it
what a creep yeah it's good though got a
great actor for this role yeah it's
great
come on Joel John Wicked their asses
[Music]
yeah this guy got lucky on the first try
oh we don't know how many houses he
visited before
[Music]
nicely done
look up in the eyes watch his soul leave
oh damn he died or not really devilish
way
yeah painful too
this sounds
creepy the sound design in this episode
is splendid
point to this map
one line from this scene I want just one
and I think you know what it is why am I
in a cage
because I'm afraid of you you're a
dangerous person you've certainly proven
that
I can see how much you care about him
but even so
you better face reality you gotta face
reality dick that part of your life it's
ending
and what I'm offering you is a beginning
but if you can't find a way to trust me
then yes you are alone
it's not a great start to the trust
building
guys need manscape products
foreign
[Music]
Silver Lake
it's a resort a resort
I'm so happy they're doing this
they're in the point to where we are and
where your Resort is
yes it better be the exact same to spot
your buddy points too
[Music]
I've never been so happy to see such a
messed up scene
go ask him he'll tell you I'm not lying
yeah
I ain't telling you [__]
okay I believe him yes
oh yes so happy so happy very well
delivered
[Music]
oh
Rosie gross gross gross for what it's
worth this is just dear meat I swear
I'd rather not
well yes we all are that's sort of the
point
yeah Fair it was a last resort you think
it doesn't shame me that would be my
first Resort
let them starve these people who put
their lives in my hands I don't think
your friend would either didn't he take
another man's life to save yours
around for the context David and you
know what I see when I look at you
I've always had a violent heart
I struggled with it for a long time then
the world ended and I was shown the
truth my God
cordyceps
huh it's fruitful it multiplies feeds
and protects its children it secures its
future with violence if it must
yes
he loves
I'm a Shepherd surrounded by sheep and
all I want
is an equal
I can tell the others to stop looking
for him they'll spare him really
just let him go
yeah
they follow me and they would follow us
Lord knows I could use the help
we grow
spread out
and we do whatever we needed for our
people
imagine the life we could build
[Music]
let's see when I go tell the others now
Ellie
what
tell them that Ellie is a little girl
who broke her [__]
yes that's all I wanted
Bella Ramsay you are awesome she better
get a nomination I swear to God the real
God not this false god David really
the cordyceps God damn look at this man
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
look at it
dude this episode has a great grip on
build what did you say
no she would have turned by now this
isn't real
pretty [__]
ah Troy Baker oh poor Troy [__] Troy
Baker man
oh I know which part we're at
oh boy
[Music]
part always freaked me out
oh yeah
[Music]
damnation
belly Ellie
Ellie that he's so creepy no one
infected fights this hard to stay alive
that's a Philippians quote no one likes
being humiliated Ellie
you don't know how good I am
you see I changed my mind
decided you do need a father
[Music]
oh crazy shot oh
I thought you already knew
the fighting is a part I like the most
oh
don't be afraid
there's no fear in love
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
God
ah okay
[Music]
okay okay
baby girl
[Music]
ah we
that is paced so well though
radio so listen we're gonna have to do
this review a little different we
decided very early on that
um we're gonna need a spoiler section
all right
we just we just need one because there's
especially some implementation they had
in this episode and I'm like I just I
have to talk so we're gonna not go into
spoilers right now uh but we'll just
stick to here
however there's going to be some stuff
that talks about the future specifically
regarding uh the second game that I
think is would be good to touch on but
um I I thought this was
an excellent episode I really did I
thought it was excellent you know it
like there are
I don't want to spend too much time
backtracking to some other episodes this
did that thing go where yeah they did
cut out some stuff that would have been
cool to bring to the big screen but they
also added in a lot of things and
expanded upon that I thought made it for
taking this section of the game that is
very they obviously they have to
condense it down but it didn't feel
rushed to me or like a short film
version I thought it was a perfectly
packaged you know uh piece that they had
to do in order to tell this chapter
which I think is really integral to the
development of Ellie uh especially
because of just the the depth she has to
ultimately go to in order to survive you
know like you
she's a Survivor like anyone else but
this is the first time where you see her
unleash
unleash a violent side of herself that
you never get to see prior you know like
you get the sense that maybe she ended
up killing Riley after Riley turned you
know
um in this show she hasn't killed any
humans yet right am I right about that
uh she I think she shot a few people but
like actually hand-to-hand combat I
believe this is her first one yeah this
is because this is like brutal I should
kill two people in this episode you know
she shot a few people yeah yeah and you
watch like sort of this
this morphing process and also would
Joel having a rescue her like this is a
real pivotal turning point for both of
these characters and you can just sort
of see it in the emotions and I thought
they did an excellent job on bringing
that to life uh I I thought it was
like yeah David's great and all uh well
I do want to talk more about him I was
really impressed with the way this
episode was paced because it was it
starts off with like really deliberate
and
the pace just kept ramping up and kept
going and going and going and then the
way they handled especially the reveal
of David like what I thought was cool
about
because if you guys haven't played the
game when they introduce him they
introduce him when Ellie's about to grab
the deer that's the first introduction
and it's immediately kind of I don't
know about this guy
you know
but then some stuff happens in the game
that they do not have here that makes
you go oh maybe he's actually an all
right guy and then you find out no he's
not he's an all right guy
so I thought they had the a neat effect
here where when they introduce him
you're like oh he's a he's a caretaker
he loves his people he's there's
something warm about him he's a family
man
so when she when they meet Ellie you're
like no no no this is one of the good
guys you know of course I've played the
game but but in the context here I
imagine if I had him play the game but
yes no he's one of the good guys he's
one of the all right guys come on
and then he's they slowly start to peel
the back yeah
like oh never mind oh never mind oh wow
really never mind this this guy snapped
in the apocalypse there you know uh and
I thought they did a really excellent
job where a lot of the tone was driven
by the drive to save Ali the drive to
protect Joel and of course the um
the end like I don't even call it
transformation more of the the unveiling
of David I thought it was instrumented
like very very well
so
yeah but Andrew you didn't get your
scene that you wanted I'm sorry oh yeah
yeah well we'll talk about that in a sec
I did think again as you just mentioned
this episode was extremely well paced
minus the scene I didn't want
um bastards Andrew yeah but again you
know what even though I was definitely I
was disappointed by that there have been
others I mean you made a great point
that the stuff that they did include did
make up for it although I really still
wear it like the reason I think that
scene is so pivotal important at least
for me yes I get it in the game it was
an action sequence so you're in control
so it's like important but I also feel
it's just so important because it shows
that Ellie is just obviously yes I get
to we get to see Ellie you know later on
in this episode where she survives on
her own and she does take care of David
of course I mean we get that in the game
as well but just seeing her fend off for
herself on her own when you know a bunch
of infected are coming after like seeing
that side of belly it's just it's I
don't know it just for me it was it was
just such an important and integral part
of the game and for Ellie's character
just fleshing her out more and I was a
little bit sad not to see it I I get why
they didn't put it in although I again I
I wish like even five minute sequence of
of that action sequence would have made
me even happy but again you can't get
everything but you know the thing that
this show has not just this episode but
this whole show Even though there have
been action sequences that to my sadness
have not been included the characters
have been absolutely I mean we talked
about this before off camera the
character
the characters have just been nailed
perfectly for the most part just across
the board absolutely now then if I had
to choose one thing I have the action
sequences on my video game whenever I
want so I know I can always go to that
would it be cool to see visually of
course I do I wish they were here
absolutely but if you if I had to pick
what you were gonna nail on an on-screen
adaptation I I would choose the
characters because I do have that action
sequence and I can play it at home so
I'm glad that they are nailing the
character-wise maybe hey maybe season
two we will get some more action
sequences that we didn't get here you
never know but again I I it did make me
feel a little better when you mentioned
yeah that's true we did get some
inclusions that we didn't get in the
game that make up for not getting that
action sequence and there were some
stuff that they had in there like the
Ellie you know tell them that Ellie's a
little girl that broke your finger like
I'm so glad they they kept that in there
and I loved uh belly's delivery in that
moment it was and it nailed the the tone
of what Ashley Johnson was going to we
got Troy Baker of course I really like
that actor a lot that they got for David
I really feel like he just nailed the
mannerisms and the tone and that that
slimy yet he feels almost like a good
guy telling to the reveal kind of
happens with of David that Nolan North
really encompassed in the video game
just really solid job by that I realized
Nolan North played him yeah it was never
I didn't realize that it was known North
so uh yeah
yeah no so I thought that actor really
nailed it again and very very well paced
episode some really cool action
sequences that we did get that carried
on from the game
um overall yeah really good episode I
love the locations I love that they
actually went on you know location to
film in some of these people in in
Colorado or where did they film in
Vancouver I believe it looks like all
right it does look like Colorado I think
it was Vancouver wherever it was I'm
glad they got to go in the
cinematography on the show is so
top-notch
um I think my my two favorite moments of
this episode were when Ellie was kind of
like you know holding Joel in the bed
like just saying with him like just like
it was such a yeah tender and such a
bonding moment just I don't maybe that
happened in the game I I'd have to reply
yeah yeah either way I love that and
then one of my favorite moments in the
game that Pedro Pasco just absolutely
nailed the line where he calls her baby
girl like that's really yeah we've had
moments of building and fleshing out of
like yes I'm accepting this this girl as
my surrogate daughter from just the
scenes where he's been so protective of
her but actually hearing him call her
baby girl like that it just it's such a
such a deep and amazing like moment the
delivery by Pedro Pascal I just it's one
of my favorite moments in the game when
Joel is so accepting yet yes
I can do the protective stuff but
actually calling her and like being
accepting that this is my daughter now
like I'm ready to to face that that fact
like I just loved and again Pedro Pascal
I just loved it and of course the
interrogation scene like absolutely
Perfection with that scene like that was
so freaking perfect I mean Pedro Pascal
like you talk about belly getting
nominated which I agree she just she
absolutely deserves it he better get
freaking nominated for for this show
like his performance I think he's
secured it yeah I think he has he's so
good I I feel like Pedro Pascal is gonna
this might sound weird I don't ever put
out a prediction like this I think he's
gonna win sexiest man alive in 2023. he
has to right it's just like I mean
there's like a Renaissance
yeah he's he's awesome yeah and then
also too in regards to Ellie like
seeing what happens to her character
seeing the transformation she's like she
basically you know when David violates
her like that and she she really to me
she loses a piece of her soul and a
piece of her innocence and it's just
interesting seeing that transformation
how we see it in the game and how you
know Bella Ramsay was able to really
show that the the facial expressions and
like I could really feel like that like
watching her on screen like just where
you feel a piece of her soul is gone
like that innocence is gone and you see
that Rage carryover which we're going to
talk about a little when we get to the
spoiler section how that rage carries on
over and so it's just yeah no it's a
it's a really tender and crazy moment
for the character that she has to go
through I mean yeah David is a I just
think David is in the game and
especially here too it's just such a
well-written villain yeah he is I think
Ellie in that scene is like reborn in
fire you know yeah and they they
do an excellent job which demonstrate
like the this chapter is so important
because this is this is when you see
Joel really sick like get ugly he gets
ugly and ruthless yeah and then you see
Ellie having to do that as well in order
to survive you know they there there
comes an understanding between the two
of them
and I think when you talk about action
scenes not being included the element
that I think
would help would have helped Aid this
is the the part is like I don't it's not
just that I want more gameplay sequences
included because I'm I really don't ever
think about that too much like I was I
was okay with missing it however
it
the one part of this world that I think
could use a like going into season two
that could help aid it is you know when
you're in the game when you're walking
around it's always scary because you
just never go like what the hell there's
some something might be at any corner
like you just never know and here
I never really get the sense that we're
ever in danger of infected being around
it's like you you kind of always know
you're kind of always
when in fact they're going to show up
you're aware like okay this is an
infected scene that's about to happen as
opposed to feeling like a constant
looming threat in any direction you know
and that that was the sequence that they
that they X out of this this episode so
I do I do think that that is an element
to the world of The Last of Us that
ought to be so it's not really so much
about I want action scenes or anything
it's really I want that threat feeling I
want that threat kind of permeating
throughout uh the experience yeah you
know also the fact to yes we know David
is a pedophile and you know like he
wants he wants Ellie around to be like
his pet and we we get that and I
understand but I just felt like two in
the game in that action sequence like
that that whole action sequence just did
a good job of building like why David
wants her around like after seeing what
she can do exactly I get what you're
getting because I did have that thought
um where like the part where I would
agree with having that action scene is
because when David's like I see this in
you I'm like you guys like you just
passed a conversation yeah yeah and yes
like while while there is you know a
much more disgusting uh quality to David
uh a much more deviant side to David
you you do get why he would think that
that others you get why he would also
buy into the other stuff is that just
saying it to take advantage of her yeah
there's also this side where he he can't
see it because he saw the kind of War
but then again like with with the game
the sequence of events plays out a
little different because like they do
the three-month time like Joel's is it
three months like Joel's been like it
was fall to winter so Joel's been
healing for a long time yes right
um and we did the winter
no no we we started winter a little bit
earlier on the show whereas in winter
like it literally starts right where the
rabbit is in the bone arrow that's
really where it starts we got our winter
jump after Henry and Sam correct so a
little bit earlier on the show and we
get but in the game you get the winter
jump uh after Joel and leave Tommy and
I'll end the and Jackson after they
leave there
he's been in the game he's been healing
yes up for a few months yeah and that's
how I was able whereas here it's like I
don't know this just all occurred within
a few days right and like that that's
So within that you get Ellie who's been
hunting and providing for them so she's
developed skills and whatnot to to be
able to survive on her own and hunt down
prey
so like that quality to building her up
I think I think when it comes to season
two we're gonna just do a big time jump
again like following the the second game
um of how things progress but anyway
yeah yeah I'm trying to watch my words
yeah but also too if you if you notice
like right when the episodes started and
we hadn't even seen David I said is he a
pasture or like I was thinking the
reason I said that is because I'm sure
many of you noticed in the video game
I'm not sure if you did this that action
sequence that I was really sad and that
we didn't get to see when they're
warding off all the clickers and the
infected and of course the bloater David
does say like he makes like a kind of a
prayer did you ever did you ever notice
that or hear that or no because I I'd
always know yeah like off to the side
it's not like a very focal point but off
to the side he kind of makes like a
prayer and I was always I always think
in my head whenever I'd see him do that
because I'd always noticed I'm like yeah
was he a priest was he a pastor like
he's very like I feel like there's
something religious here so that's why
in the beginning I was like I wonder if
they're gonna go that route and then
when I heard that I was like oh that's
why I was thinking that so I was glad
that they did expand upon that from the
game I had a feeling we were possibly
going to go there
um but also too I remember that line in
the game where he said oh we're all
starving women children I always thought
that was kind of a lying line that he
was just trying to get Ellie's trust so
actually seeing it here like I mean yeah
he was trying to get her trust but it's
like no he act actually we're women and
children who were starving so it was
like there was I mean kind of humanizes
and I know we were kind of making a joke
we're humanizing the cannibals now too
like we gotta humanize everyone well
they do specify that not everyone here
is aware of what they're consuming I
think I think you know Troy Baker
brought a lot to this role yeah he was
great as James I I thought he brought so
you could feel like the history in his
eyes and these little exchanges of being
like yeah David's my leader but there's
so much parts in the exchanges like they
have that thing where he calls him out
for being doubtful yeah and you could
see that he he doubts the way the
leadership has progressed in the path
they've had to go down he's even like
there's even this this hardened part of
himself when it comes to his time to eat
the food oh yeah another body language
yeah for sure where he doesn't want to
do it but he's like this is my life now
you know and I I there is uh there's um
there is a level of there's a big level
of Gravitas to what he bring the pathos
is more of the word I would say for what
Troy Baker brought to this specific
portrayal like I'm like damn there's a
he really yeah really bright he's not
just here for like a cami like this is a
real role like he's a body no he's great
I mean yeah yeah he said that there was
that one line or so where it kind of
sounded like the Joel voices coming out
a little bit but no I agree with you and
if I didn't know what was going to
happen because I remember what happened
to his character James in the video game
which I knew was gonna happen here uh
with Ellie taking the butcher knife to
his neck after tricking them that she's
been infected I really thought too they
did a good job of setting up the
audience who had not played the game of
kind of like yeah he's losing faith in
David like there's a good chance David
might execute him at some point too like
they were really doing a good job of
like setting that up for the audience
who has not played the video games
because I mean even though I knew that
was kind of I was like I almost feel
like they might stray away from the game
and go that route just because of how
much like he's calling him kind of
calling him out and just lost faith in
him and like David can't show weakness
in leadership so I just I thought that
was interesting that they were doing
that so I really think they did a great
job on slowly pulling back the layers of
David yes I thought that was like that
the actor too was perfectly sync with
right with the script yeah and the
direction of knowing of how much more of
his evil has to be unveiled per scene I
can see the complaints now though about
him right now on the internet if there
are any he doesn't look like David from
the video game I don't know I don't I'm
still a white guy and I still got a
white guy yeah exactly no I mean I
personally like I said he nailed the
mannerisms of no and and he sounded very
similar to Nolan North uh and again I
just love how they peeled black and
flush the character out even more
expanded upon the character is the word
and I love how they again expanded upon
just the whole town as a whole and just
showed David as a leader I just thought
all that stuff was really it was very
meticulous and very interesting well the
the way they also unveil the way he
deals with his own faith of its
manipulation tactic and he's really
succumbed to the worship of the
cordyceps yes as that is his new deity I
thought that was a really fascinating
layer that was
um this apocalyptic worship you know it
was those are crazy inclusion and like I
I I'm surprised we don't have anything
like that in the game like there's not
of both games there's nothing about that
in the in either of the game well I mean
Neil druckman has always said if we can
improve upon anything from the game I
mean if we're gonna if we stay faithful
again we're going to stay faithful the
game but there's something we can
improve upon we're gonna do it whether
it's faithful or not so now I definitely
I I'm glad they've adopted adapted to
that method like the cordyceps are our
new Lords you know that's interesting
yeah yeah it's it's a fascinating
version of being an apostle in this
situation yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
exactly yeah obviously no no one who
hasn't played uh yes will understand
that but yes I agree with you I but guys
um yeah we're going to talk about some
spoilery stuff right now so if you
haven't played thank you for being here
bye shirt uh if if you if you don't want
to hear anything about what more than
likely will come up
uh then because I I think when playing
this game before I go to spoilers but I
think when playing this section when I
when I there's choices in the second
game that very much upset the audience
yeah I wonder what you're talking about
and when I played the second game for
the first time when those choices first
presented themselves like I love the
second game I preferred over the first
um but when those choices first
presented themselves I I remember being
upset
however when I replayed both the first
game and the second game like pretty
much right away it was this chapter that
made me go oh no wait this flows really
well now into the second game like I'm
not upset at all by the choice because
this chapter really sets that up and
then this episode made it even more of a
setup that I went oh what an interesting
way to condense it down instead of a
bunch of hunters he kills to just one
guy so that's what I'm gonna talk about
here so I would click off right now uh
if you made it this far but yeah
um for those who played the second game
or at least are aware of what happens in
it is that Joel is killed by Abby and
why is because without going into every
single detail Abby's father was murdered
by Joel Dr Jerry Anderson and now here
there bringing that over here in a way
that is like a setup yeah for what is to
come because when I played the game when
you get to this section and you get all
these people who are hunting down Joel
they want Joel's head
it was already to me telegraphing that
oh people are coming for Joel and Joel's
going to die like the first game was
already saying that to us and then you
get to the second game you're like well
there it is people came for Joel and
then they made it even more more on the
nose here by going this girl's dad was
killed by Joel We gotta find this guy
and kill him it is massive foreshadowing
oh for uh what I was thinking for for
the second game that I think because
it's going to be hard for people to
swallow that who are not familiar with
the game it's going to be really hot
like people who are familiar game can
already have it there's already enough
people have a hard time with it you know
I've also been reading so many comments
too that's saying they better change up
what they did in the second game like
they're not look how faithful this
season has been like dude you're not
yeah you're not getting what you want
sorry I know Joel's dying yeah a
thousand percentage Yeah I mean Abby's
going to get a Joel in one we already
know that so I mean you know uh no I
agree with you they clearly really
foreshadowed that here I mean I was
thinking that right when we mentioned
that it was her dad was in my head I was
just going at this is total Abby
foreshadowing so I mean yeah it does
show that I mean if you remember to to
that game for anyone who played or
watched the gameplay of what happens you
know Joel says to her likes why don't
you save whatever speech you got or
whatever he says like he knows there are
consequences to what he's done like he
knows his life is over in the Moment
Like and Joel's accepting of that he
obviously he doesn't want him to die but
he's accepting like hey I know I've hurt
a lot of people in the past obviously
it's you know he's defending himself or
surviving or whatever the case may be
but he knows he has killed a lot of
people and those people have families so
again he's very accepting of the fact
that hey uh this is clearly someone I've
hurt in the past someone is related to
someone I don't know exactly who but my
life is over it is what it is it sucks
but it is what it is yeah I know but I I
mean again they did a good job of
foreshadowing that here so that
even the people who are not going to be
happy with that can understand like hey
it sucks what's gonna happen but you
understand like even though it was
clearly obviously self-defense and what
happens here what happens in the game
again people who are here you're already
you already know what happened it wasn't
self-defense in regard to when he kills
Dr Jerry Anderson that particular case
was not self-defense whether Abby was
prone to know if that was self-defense I
mean it's really it doesn't matter at
that point or all she knows is her dad's
dead and she just wants the guy who
killed her she's bent on Revenge so I
mean we go from that stage but
um in regards to this one again whether
it's self-defense or not it doesn't
matter these you know you are affecting
other people's lives when you kill
someone and they've got a family member
and so again they did it like you said
they did a great job of foreshadowing
that setting that up whether people are
going to like that or not it it you know
it's I I don't think it matters uh what
just matters is that it's executed
properly and you know I think we're all
going to be heartbroken and sad when
that when that comes I'm I am curious
though obviously we know it's going to
happen in season two
how early are you gonna do that in
season two like I hope it's the opening
scene first scene the first scene no no
but it's cut to Joel's head I mean
because a lot of these I mean the first
couple episodes of this season were
really freaking long which I loved
um so I'm wondering like maybe episode
three maybe episode I don't know what I
mean I'm very curious to see how they're
going to do that because again like
we've talked about
Last of Us Part Two is like five times
longer than the first game so you were
able to do the first game in Nine
episodes
I don't know if they're gonna have to
split it up in a couple of Seasons when
we get to season two or you're gonna
have to do 18. I'm very curious how
they're gonna do all that because you
are not doing season two in Nine
episodes like that's just in my opinion
that's just not happening not it not at
the length of episodes that we're
getting here in my opinion I mean what
are your thoughts do you think they're
they're able to be able to do season two
in Nine episodes I think they can do it
in five I think all you got when I said
that I knew who's coming with it all you
got to do is uh
focus on Abby I don't care to see
healthy stories just take it all from
Abby's perspective but again like I was
talking about too like seeing the loss
of of Ellie's innocence and her soul
basically I mean you said being reborn
in Fire and all that which I agree with
a lot of that rage carries over into the
second game so again you talk about the
foreshadowing what happened with yeah
you know the it's a very important
chapter yeah no I mean like but that's
the thing like when I just went straight
into the second game like where's all
this pent-up energy coming from with
Ellie and then when I replayed both the
first and the second game back to back
I'm like ah okay this chapter is just so
integral and like where that violence
and that rage just comes around it's
freaking David like got it out of her so
yeah no I I think part two is just I
mean it's a great game on its own but it
just goes so much better when you play
it immediately after the first game it
does that's how I'd recommend for people
to play it like skip the first game just
go right you most people waited years
and then they played it you know exactly
which yeah don't affect the experience
yeah all right guys well that's it for
today's episode uh what'd you think
about it did you like it did you love it
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
follow Andrew don't forget to buy a
shirt don't forget to buy don't forget
to mention how cringe-worthy I was
Andrew pick any name watch it watch
anything with Gabriel and Dave's has
ever been shouted out uh Petty name any
name I'll make it work let's go with
come on buddy go with Lance Lance door
Lance is uh like if there's some common
facts we know about Lance all right
Canadian fella ah I'm half Canadian did
you know that are you I'm half Canadian
my father wow that's awesome no
um he's also a fi a firefighter and he's
got like a hot wife and a really cool
kid
so what a lot of people don't know about
Lance though is that actually and I
gotta be very careful of my words here
he's not a very interesting man
he's actually quite dull
the reason why his woman loves him so
much
let's just say he's got a really big
fire hose you know what I mean
I understood that reference and uh
he sent me photos now normally
I tell followers maybe you shouldn't be
sending me photos of those things
because it's inappropriate
but boy did I keep asking for more from
Lance and he kept delivering the goods
sometimes
in a actual fire situation
they don't even use what's on the fire
truck
when they're not able to access a fire
hydrant
they call upon Lance
and he just unzips
and does his thing
he has saved many lives with
with that fire hose of his so he sent
you the fire hose how about the ax his
helmet any any pictures of those as well
are we talking about the same thing are
you talking about it actual ax at a
helmet or do you mean a photo of his
big ax
whichever one you want to use your
imagination for
yeah he sent me a photo of an actual ax
it was really cool it was really sharp
and made of uh it was red full of and
super sharp and uh the helmet as well he
sent me a physical one but the fire hose
I'm talking about is Ah that's what I
thought no Lance is a great guy there's
more to him than his fire hose
I just want to know if the line from
Batman Forever was true when he said to
Dr Chase Meridian try firemen less to
take off I just want to know if that
line is true Lance let us know
I think we both need some sleep
[Music]